i know we can't do some correlation with
it but it seems that summer's a season
of blockbusters maybe it's the hollywood
perception but think about it not too
long ago summer brought us big hits like
classroom of the elite and made an abyss
five years later and
you know let us get to the list before i
spoil the surprise but just now that i'm
looking at the summer 2022 charts i find
myself staring down a whole line of
great shows ahead it may not be as big
of a smash hit to mainstream audiences
as winter but it sure is pretty loaded
with a lot of shows to get excited about
but hey if you're feeling hungry or in
the mood for some positivity why don't
you check out today's sponsors sakurako
and tokyo treat sakurako and tokyo treat
are subscription-based boxes that look
to provide you with the coolest snacks
straight from the swedes capital of asia
japan while the two boxes both offer
some of the best japan has to offer the
cool thing is that they both bring a
different side of japan to you sakurako
is more oriented towards the more
traditionalist side of the country which
contains authentic and artisan snacks
and this month's theme is taste of
hokkaido i'm talking tea and other
delights straight from the north
meanwhile those of you who've been
enjoying your boy kong ming will
definitely love tokyo treats box for
this month as it brings to you some of
the best modern seasonal and exclusive
japanese snacks from downtown tokyo this
is snacking shibuya for you and with a
lineup like this i can't even pick the
suite that i want to start with but this
pudding flavored kitkat was just amazing
and you definitely gotta taste it so
check out the link in the description
box and use code vinnie to get five
dollars off your first box i hope you
can have as much of a great time as i
did so i invite you to give these boxes
a shot
getting the isakai's out fast and quick
my isakai life is the latest addition to
the ever-growing library of isakai
titles so what's the gimmick this time
monster taming power fantasy summoned as
a monster tamer yuji sano finds himself
saddled with the burden of a job that
makes it hard to be an adventurer
however being a monster tamer doesn't
come with zero perks not when it lets
him meet some awesome slimes read some
magical books and sees himself becoming
more than just a monster tamer no this
guy is now a sage and with this
overwhelming power he looks to become
the strongest in the world from this
synopsis i'm getting some serious ari
fury at the vibes don't you seemingly
useless job turns some slob useful and
kicks off his road to become the
strongest in the world it's the surefire
formula for a power fantasy and if
you're into the genre you might like the
show for this
[Music]
next on the list is call of the night
now here's some vampire action for you
but perhaps not the type you'd expect i
mean our protagonist is a listless
middle school student feeling bored in
putting up his facade of being the model
student he quit school and starts his
downward spiral in life developing
insomnia in the process the weird girl
nazuna determines the source of his
problems an internal will that holds him
back from experiencing true freedom and
so she invites him to her apartment and
plants the vampire's kiss i know i've
seen the premise of call of the night
somewhere already but the manga does
bring something great to the table it's
one of those cozy comedic reads that
reels you in with easy going atmosphere
before also incorporating genres like
mystery quite a fun read from the
creator of dargah shikashi with an
all-star cast manning the anime
production team i've got some high hopes
for this one
[Music]
at number eight we have the fourth
season of don machi
[Music]
it's been a long road for dhanmachi fans
here when the thing first aired i didn't
expect it to get this far but three
seasons in a movie later here we are
danmachi returns with its fourth season
this summer it's as a series had its
share of ups and downs while i'd say
that the franchise is in a decent spot
right now the past few seasons haven't
actually gotten on the fans goodwill
with the cut content however with the
source material that the anime team has
for this fourth season i can't get any
more excited how can i not when the
season will cover one of the best arcs
in the entire series we'll get densely
packed arcs with amazing action hyped
encounters and dungeon challenges like
we've never seen before as a parting
note ryu and freya fans will have
something to look forward to so make
sure to stay tuned
seventh in line is bastard
[Music]
now that's a name i haven't heard in a
while bastard's never been the most
popular anime out there in the 90s so
seeing this get a modernized version is
nothing short of a surprise the story is
basically a dark fantasy set in
post-apocalyptic earth with the kingdom
of metallicana being threatened by mages
seeking to awaken the god of destruction
hybrid's geo decides to proverbially
push the panic button in his desperation
in doing so he unleashes the powerful
wizard dark schneider unsealing the dark
wizard can be the kingdom's only hope
against the four lords of havoc but
could his presence turn the tide of
battle from bad to worse combining the
standard fare of fantasy magic as well
as a cast of morally ambiguous
characters bastard felt like it was
ahead of the curve in its time throw in
the wacky metal band references and
you'll see why people often compare this
to both jojo and berserk fans of both
series will have something to watch and
it's coming this summer thanks to
netflix
next up we have the next season of
overlord
now this is a series i'm not surprised
got a fourth season overlord was a
pioneer in its time back when the isekai
boom was just starting to go full
throttle who knew that watching an
overpowered overlord no pun intended
there making fibo denizens kneel can be
so entertaining the series quickly
captured the hearts of many and easily
became one of the community's favorite
itsakai eins and the gang are back for
the fourth installment of the series
this summer if the pattern holds true
overlord's fourth season should cover
volumes 10 to 12 of the novel source
material readers know what to expect
kingdom building adventures to the dwarf
kingdom and possibly one hell of a
cliffhanger leading to the much
anticipated holy kingdom arc me well i'm
just so glad to see irons raise hell and
flex his prowess again glad to have you
back overlord
rent a girlfriend is making its return
girlfriend didn't take too long to make
an impact it's one of the most
polarizing series now for many reasons
but as they say polarized publicity is
better than nothing and it's propelled
the series into getting a second season
you've got to thank the discussions and
weekly social media buzz for that i
think well what else can i say about
rent a girlfriend i always compare it to
the likes of nisakoi and girlfriend
girlfriend in a sense that it's the show
that bumbles around with the slice of
life shenanigans developing the girls
and raising their stock for fans to get
invested in before catching us with a
major revelation or two look for more of
the same in the second season of rent a
girlfriend which means more memes more
cute moments more kazuya establishing
himself as the most controversial hero
in the genre and more community
craziness that only rent a girlfriend
can cause i'm definitely looking forward
to this one
classroom of the elite makes its much
anticipated return
nothing is impossible goes and all added
nobody ever thought that classroom of
the elite would get a second chance at
the limelight but here we are hey though
we've learned from the tawaro series
already right also another testament to
this coming up later for those who
weren't around back then because it
really was a long time ago classroom of
the elite tells of a utopian school
students enjoy unparalleled freedom in
this prestigious academy save for the
lowest of the loan class d is where the
school dumps the worst students and it's
here that we find kiyotaka brilliant but
lazy he gets paired with the unsociable
suzune and the pepe class idol geekio
will this odd trio overcome the odds and
reach the top of the school rankings now
that's the premise of the series in a
nutshell i'm honestly more curious as to
how they'll fix things for the second
season considering the changes they did
with character writing in the first one
yeah light novel adaptation syndrome but
much more magnified than usual either
way i'm excited to see the gang back so
i'll be keeping this in my sights
next up is a surprise lucifer and the
biscuit hammer wow how long has it been
since i heard that name the manga has
generated quite a buzz in the 2000s but
almost two decades later it will be
getting its anime adaptation in this
series the world is threatened by a mage
in his biscuit hammer a gigantic mallet
in space getting ready to deliver the
final smash to end the world to prevent
this our hero amamiya yuhi must join the
princess and a ragtag group of misfits
the beast knights while yuhi wants no
part in saving the world he's indeed
interested in serving the princess who
wants to save the world just so she can
destroy it herself thus the cult classic
is finally coming in anime form it's
strange wild and entertaining but all in
a good way it's an adventure series that
combines magic a very fun ragtag group
of characters and pinches of romance is
quite convoluted at times but it's an
odd tale that's a lot more enjoyable
than it might seem at first in second
place it's devil is a part-timer
no more a decade later devil is a
part-timer finally gets its second
season the world's changed and the light
novel's ending has been controversial to
say the least but that doesn't mean that
all the enthusiasm has been lost as the
community reacted with joy when this
announcement was made devil is a
part-timer is a very popular isakai back
in its day it tells of the demon lord
sadao being driven to earth thanks to
the efforts of the hero emmy yusuf
determined to finish the job emmy
follows him to earth only to find out
that both of them have lost their powers
unfortunately the two end up being fish
out of water on earth forced into
bottom-rung jobs and the hardships of
human life such as you know bills and
rent and stuff like that eventually
their past catches up to them and one
has to wonder how they have to deal with
threats coming from their previous world
and thus the adventure continues with
the second season of devil is a
part-timer the first season has quite
the legacy to speak of so you better get
watching it before hopping into the
second one it's completely worth a shot
and it will help you get up to speed
with what to expect from season two
[Applause]
to top off our list our most anticipated
anime this summer 2022 is made in abyss
the golden city of the scorching sun
after the third movie comes this next
installment to in abyss renowned as one
of the best anime in the past decade
made in abyss as a franchise has
continued taking us on this breathtaking
descent down the abyss in this
installment rico and nanachi delve
further and reach the sixth layer the
capital of the unreturned as no one's
ever returned to the surface after
reaching this majestic city this looks
to be the toughest trial that the trio
will take on so far and given all the
curses that the previous layers had what
else could top it all off how about
actual death how would our plucky
adventurers survive the horrors of the
sixth layer there's only one way to find
out and it's to watch the continuation
to one of the best anime in the previous
decade coming to you this summer
[Music]
so which anime are you looking forward
to the most this summer i'd love to hear
your thoughts on the video in this list
i've made so go ahead and fill the
comments section with your thoughts as
usual like and share the video to help
the channel reach that million
subscriber milestone and i'll be looking
to talk with you more through my social
media channels discord patreon instagram
channel memberships we have it all and
all you have to do is check out the
description box don't forget to check
out our sponsors of this video monthly
japanese snack subscription boxes tokyo
treat and sakuraku links are in the
description once again thank you for
watching and i hope to see you soon for
my next list